outside the stadium Martha where did it
all go wrong I think it went wrong even
before the England team got to the
stadium they were actually about 20
minutes late they got stuck in the
notorious Tokyo traffic which they know
very well about they've dealt with it
for much of the tournament when they've
been playing games here
so they got on that bus a little bit
late and then it got stuck in traffic
and they arrived here late which meant
that they weren't out on the field when
they were supposed to be to do their pre
match walnuts the likes of Owen
Farrell's always out there bang on an
hour before he was about 15 minutes late
but that was really what you'd consider
a minor hiccup it's the sort of thing
that you would think that England would
be able to deal with with an event of
the magnitude of a World Cup final but
they started horribly and it got even
worse straight away within three minutes
they're poor Kyle Singler who's been so
brilliant this entire tournament was
knocked out cold he was on the pitch for
several minutes while they did the head
injury assessment the new Rugby protocol
which means he says any suspicion of a
concussion the player has to leave the
pitch and can't reenter and so that was
a big blow for England to lose him early
on but really they were never in this
game they didn't have any answer for the
South Africans the South Africans
discipline their speed their energy I
think it just took England completely by
surprise it was a coaching masterclass
by the South South African coach
Razi Erasmus an England really did have
no answer in hand ray Paul had kicked
very well for the South Africans there
was a small glimmer of hope for England
on that 15-minute mark
and there was a scrum England had had no
look in the scrums up to that point and
but they managed to get advantage in
that scrum they then scored a penalty
owen farrell not not quite on his game
kicking wise and but he did manage to
score a penalty and they were in touch
and till those last two devastating
tries bounced at by South Africa and you
have to hand it to them it was an
incredible performance
they weren't handed this world cup they
won it